denn frank jetzt gerade ist natürlich
auch die große angst in wien dass noch
nicht alle täter festgenommen werden
konnte man weiß noch nicht mal wie viele
täter genau es sind was macht das jetzt
so gefährlich und vor allem kann man
irgendwie einschätzen wie lange die
täter tatsächlich ja versteckt bleiben
können bis die einsatzkräfte sie dann
finden oder ein zugriff sich dann
erlaubt es gibt halt mehrere gefahren
auf der einen seite habe ich eben schon
beschrieben es kann immer sein dass
diese täter möglicherweise auch geiseln
nehmen und sich dort verschanzen und
menschen als lebende schutzschilde
benutzen
zum anderen haben wir es erlebt bei dem
anschlag auf den weihnachtsmarkt in
straßburg vor knapp zwei jahren da war
es eben so dass der täter sich etwas
drei tage in einer leeren lager wieder
versteckt an der nähe des tatortes die
polizei immer dachte er sei geflüchtet
sei mittlerweile schon im ausland es
gebe auch hinweise darauf er sei
vielleicht nach deutschland geflüchtet
aber er war nur mehr wenige hundert
meter vom tatort entfernt in einer
lagerhalle war immer noch bewaffnet und
das ist natürlich hier auch das problem
für die einsatzkräfte
man weiß ja immer noch nicht genau wie
viele täter sind es wirklich die rede
ist immer von zwei oder drei täter man
weiß es aber nicht genau am ende ist es
vielleicht auch wieder nur einen täter
wie in münchen damals
man weiß es nicht genau und das ist ein
großes problem solange man nicht
wirklich genau weiß wie viele täter es
sind oder wie viele täter unterwegs
waren kann man natürlich auch nicht
sagen ob man alle hat und das ist jetzt
eine große herausforderung für die
polizei wenn es die lage erst mal soweit
unter kontrolle haben herauszufinden ist
noch irgendwo ein täter versteckt sich
ein täter hält es sich irgendwann einer
wohnung auf bedroht menschen hat geiseln
genommen das ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
natürlich noch völlig unklar
frank du hast als reporter von vielen
terroranschlägen berichtet unter anderem
aus frankreich siehst du da tatsächlich
diese parallelen glaubst du die haben
sich da etwas abgeschaut von dem was
damals eben backnang und anderen
passiert ist ja ich muss sagen zum glück
sind sie nicht so professionell
vorgegangen ich bin allerdings eben
regelrecht zusammengezuckt innerlich
weil ich in einem video gesehen haben
einem augenzeugen video wie
polizeibeamte geschossen wurden und dann
sprühten wieder die funken von den
patronen von den kugeln die dort auf den
asphalt aufschlug und das erinnerte mich
doch ganz stark damals an dass ballack
noch
die polizisten die dort anrückten auch
aus dem batliner von den terroristen
erschossen wurden und da war das so
ähnlich da waren auch die projektile die
in den asphalt aufschlug und sprühten
funken und das war eben schon eine
situation wo ich dachte nicht schon
wieder
und das ist sicherlich schon so dass sie
offenbar ja wenn es denn mehrere täter
sind versucht haben zeitgleich in der
stadt auch und restaurants was er
gesehen da war teilweise außenbestuhlung
umgekippt offenbar auch restaurants oder
cafés auf passanten einfach geschossen
haben so ähnlich war es ja auch um paris
man kann hier hin muss schon glück sagen
dass sie offenbar es dazu auch eben das
gericht möglicherweise einen
sprengstoffgürtel aber von einer
explosion hinaus informationen gibt es
dann noch keine offenbar eben keine
sprengsätze genutzt haben und dann
offenbar zum glück doch nicht so gezielt
und so ja da ist dann so abgeklärt und
eiskalt vorgehen auf der anderen seite
gibt es einen augenzeugen video wo man
sieht dass der täter oder einer der
täter einen passanten an einem
schaufenster nieder schießt erst mal weg
läuft mit dem gewehr zurückkommt eine
pistole zieht und aus kurzer distanz via
man muss wirklich sagen das opfer
regelrecht hingerichtet liquidiert noch
mal mit der pistole auf das opfer
schießt was wiederum doch ein stück weit
zeigt dass es dort offenbar eine
ausbildung gegeben hat denn das ist das
typische vorgehen was dschihadisten in
ihrer ausbildung in arabischen ländern
bekommen so nach dem motto das opfer
gezielt töten sicher sein dass es tot
ist das lässt einen schon ein bisschen
dass gute den adern gefrieren und man
weiß nicht ob diese täter möglicherweise
doch noch weitere opfer finden momentan
bekommen wenn er keine informationen
mehr ob es noch die schusswechsel
gekommen in der stadt oder auch die
täter bekämpft sind man muss jetzt wie
gesagt abwarten sind es wirklich diese
mehreren täter ist es nachher doch
vielleicht nur dieser eine täter der an
verschiedenen stellen geschossen hat das
wäre ja eine große hoffnung dass es dann
am ende doch bei denen zwar schlimm aber
dann doch nicht so schlimm opferzahlen
gibt du hast nicht eben auf angesprochen
die es damals in paris war da waren es
ja ganz ganz andere opferzahlen hier
sieht man die szene noch einmal die ich
eben beschrieben habe die auch wenn auch
verschießt er kommt kurze zeit später
wieder und schießt dann erneut eben
eiskalt mit der pistole noch mal auf das
opfer war schon verwundet am boden liegt
und das ist wie gesagt etwas was dafür
spricht dass sie offenbar doch in
irgendeiner form irgendwo eine
ausbildung bekommen haben es kann
natürlich auch sein dass es sich um
rückkehrer an
man sieht es jetzt hier kehrte gerade
zurückzieht nochmal eine pistole
erschießt erneut auf das opfer
es gibt ja immer mehr rückkehrer die
auch aus den gebieten zurückgekehrt sind
und eben nicht auf offiziellem wege als
die polizei sie im visier hat das sisi
observieren kann dass sie teilweise auch
in haft nehmen kann
teilweise kommen sie eben auch illegalen
wegen zurück und da ist die große frage
möglicherweise das auch so ein kommando
sein könnte aber da muss man abwarten
ist es zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
spekulation wenn sie die täter dann
endgültig haben oder auch getöteten
einen täter soll er möglicherweise von
polizisten getötet worden sein
herauszufinden wer sind diese täter
gewesen woher kommen sie
und dann muss man auch gucken ob da noch
ein anderes netzwerk dahinter steckt
oder ob es möglicherweise ein anschlag
ist er auch noch andere dinge nach sich
zieht hier in europa vielleicht noch ein
satz dazu
die deutschen sicherheitsbehörden sind
natürlich jetzt auch in der nacht sehr
alarmiert es gibt auch überlegungen
gerade den objektschutz vor synagogen
und die technischen einrichtungen zu
verstärken weil es ja hier eben auch den
eindruck gibt es dass möglicherweise der
anlass punkt gewesen ist zum anderen hat
man auch große sorge dass das jetzt eben
zu einer welle führen kann eben andere
dschihadisten sich auch gemüse fühlen
jetzt auch loszuschlagen so nach dem
motto in der islamistischen welt ist
halt gerade diese makro geschichte und
die karikaturen ein großes thema wir
haben ja auch gesehen in deutschland
sind ja auch gerade in berlin
auch islamisten durch die straßen
gelaufen wir haben gehört von von auch
in frankreich das in kirchen teilweise
junge männer männer randaliert haben
auch in wien soll ist das ja gegeben
haben vor wenigen tagen da muss man
jetzt wirklich abwarten ob das so eine
wirkliche welle nach sich zieht zum
anderen hat die polizei natürlich auch
größte sorge dass möglicherweise auch
rechtsradikale diese taten für ihre
zwecke nutzen und sozusagen zu
gegenreaktionen übergehen also die
polizei auch gerade in deutschland er
ist extrem sensibilisiert ich würde ich
sagen beunruhigt aber sehr
sensibilisiert und versucht die
situation im blick zu behalten dass wir
nicht ihnen das nächste land etwas
möglicherweise sich anschlägen
ausgesetzt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren